november 28 1953 new york city
at 2 30 a.m the body hit the sidewalk a
few seconds later a shower of glass the
doorman of the statler hotel yelled to
the lobby that there was a jumper the
night manager rushed out and saw him a
man about 40 years old lying on the
pavement he was on his back wearing only
his underwear and blood started to pool
around him thirteen stories up a single
window is open its curtain flapping
through broken glass the night manager
knelt beside the man whose eyes were
open and was somehow still alive he
desperately tried to speak but was
choking on blood and couldn't be
understood after a minute or two of
trying to communicate the man took a
final deep breath and was gone
nobody knows for sure what he was trying
to say before he died but one thing is
for certain it was something about the
cia
room 1018a was registered to robert
lashbrook and frank olson the police
burst in guns raised but it was empty
cold november air was blowing through
the broken window in the bathroom was a
man sitting on the toilet resting his
head in his hands he told the police
he'd been sleeping heard a noise and
woke up one officer asked the name of
the man who went out the window the man
in the bathroom said olson frank olson
the responding officers figured this was
an open and shut case a middle-aged man
is depressed or distraught and ends it
all by jumping just another night in the
big city but the night manager armin
pastore wasn't convinced he said it
didn't make sense that someone would get
up in the middle of the night run across
a dark room in his underwear avoid two
beds and dive through a closed window
that had the shade and curtains closed
pastore checked with the hotel operator
to see if any calls were made from the
room the operator said yes a call was
just made a few minutes ago and because
it ran through a switchboard she heard
the whole thing the caller robert
lashbrook who is the man in the bathroom
called a number on long island which
belonged to a dr harold abramson the
call lasted only a few seconds
well he's gone lashbrook said well
that's too bad was abramson's reply a
few hours later frank olson's family was
notified they were told there was an
accident frank had either fallen or
jumped from his 10th floor room frank's
body was so badly damaged that the
funeral was held with a closed casket
and the olsen family tried to move on
having trouble coping with losing his
father eric olsen would ask his mother
about frank from time to time and she
would always say the same thing
you're never going to know what happened
in the room that night
but 20 years later that would change
in 1975 the rockefeller commission
released information to the public about
its investigation into cia activities
the report mentioned a civilian
scientist working for the department of
the navy he was given lsd without his
knowledge as part of a cia experiment
that scientist experienced side effects
and was sent to new york for psychiatric
care a few days later he jumped from a
10th floor window of his hotel and died
this report was in the new york times
and washington post and made its way to
the olsen family the government
confirmed the scientist was frank olson
and just 10 days later the family was
invited to the white house and president
ford gave them a formal apology the
director of the cia also apologized the
united states government agreed this was
a wrongful death and offered the family
a 750 thousand dollar settlement if they
agreed not to sue the olsen family
agreed to the terms alice olsen never
wanted to talk about frank's death or
his job
frank's children now in their 20s and
30s always knew their father was a
scientist but what science's family gets
a personal invitation to the oval office
alice olsen only knew a few things about
her husband's job she knew he was a
scientist doing important work for the
us government she knew he traveled for
work all the time and she knew he was
unhappy one of the last things frank
said to his wife was that he had made a
terrible mistake but for frank's
children this information was entirely
new and because of the investigations
and media coverage they now learned for
the first time what their father
actually did for a living
he was no ordinary scientist
during world war ii frank olson was one
of the first army scientists assigned to
the top secret biological warfare lab at
fort detrick maryland frank's specialty
was aerosolizing living biological
agents and munitions in other words he
created biological weapons of mass
destruction now this time in history the
cia was part of the army
after becoming a civilian frank
continued his research in bioweapons he
was lead scientist for operation harness
where animals in the caribbean were
exposed to anthrax tularemia and
brucella he was part of operation sea
spray where different strains of
bacteria were sprayed over the san
francisco bay area to test the city's
vulnerability to a bioweapon attack and
as frank moved up the ranks of the cia
he spent a lot of time at fort terry
which was a secret installation on plum
island in the long island sound plum
island is only reachable by boat or by
air the toxins tested there are
considered too dangerous to be on the
mainland olson developed delivery
devices for these bioweapons canisters
disguised as shaving cream cans that
could disperse anthrax in a concentrated
area a cigarette lighter that emitted a
deadly gas lipstick that killed
instantly heyo when did they make
biological weapons of war crime the
geneva conventions in 1925. so all this
research was illegal right in early 1953
the same year he died frank olson
stepped down as chief of the special
operations division he said the job was
too stressful and was causing his ulcers
to flare up you think ulcers suck try
anthrax oh no sympathy for cia
scientists huh not even a little bit so
frank stepped down but he stayed with
the cia
and that's when he met sydney gottlieb
and robert lashbrook got leave gottlieb
where do i know that name from well
sydney gottlieb ran the cia's project
bluebird which became project artichoke
which became mk ultra bingo
during the cold war the cia specifically
sydney gottlieb was obsessed with mind
control and brainwashing there was a
fear that the soviet union was also
working on this capability and the
united states was determined to get
there first project mk-ultra was the
program intended to accomplish this
mk-ultra was brutal and illegal over
time the experiments frank olson
conducted and witnessed started to weigh
on him during one study frank olson
observed interrogations at cia black
sites in germany detainees were called
expendables i'm assuming these
expendables were not aging action stars
they were not they were mostly suspected
spies and security leaks suspected so uh
not proven nope just suspected freaking
spooks the expendables were subject to
drug experiments hypnosis electric
shocks isolation sexual abuse and all
kinds of torture this was an effort to
study not just the effects of extreme
torture but also brainwashing techniques
and memory deletion many of these people
were interrogated to death in other
instances frank olson saw the results of
his own weapons that were used on
expendables some of those people died
slowly and in agony and even though
frank's wife didn't know any of the
specifics it was clear that frank's work
was becoming too much for him to bear in
november 1953 frank olson received an
invitation for a pre-thanksgiving
retreat at a cabin on deep creek lake
gottlieb ran these retreats for
scientists and staff pretty often deep
creek was a convenient place for god
leap this was one of the locations where
americans were subjected to mkultra
techniques against their will for
decades frank olson was there with 10
other scientists the first day of the
gathering was fine nothing out of the
ordinary on the second day after dinner
the men kicked back for a post-meal
drink lashbrook got leeb's second in
command pulled a bunch of glasses and
poured everyone a generous portion of
cointreau which is an excellent orange
triple sec lakua from france right 20
minutes later gottlieb asked if anyone
was feeling odd a few of the men said
they were godly then told them that
their drinks were spiked with a heavy
dose of lsd son
frank olson was aware that the cia had
dosed entire villages in europe to
observe the results
many innocent people died from these
experiments but he was surprised that he
would be the unwitting subject of an
experiment and frank didn't react well a
few days later he submitted his
resignation but he was talked into
staying it was suggested that he see a
psychiatrist to help him cope with the
effects of the experiment and the stress
of his work frank agreed lash brook
drove frank olson to new york to meet
with dr harold abramson this is the guy
he called after the jump right yep
dr abramson was actually an allergist
that worked for the cia he pretended to
be a psychiatrist but frank didn't know
this after a couple of sessions dr
abramson convinced frank to check
himself into a hospital so he could
recover from stress and exhaustion frank
was actually fine with this he was
looking forward to the time off and was
already picking out what books to bring
with him and that night he and lashbrook
signed into the statler hotel room 1018a
frank had a nice conversation with his
wife she remembered him sounding more
peaceful than he'd been in a long time
he watched a little tv and went to bed
at 2 30 am he was dead on the street
below the window over the next 12 hours
a cleanup and a cover-up by the c.i.a
ensued the police investigation was
quickly closed frank olson's family was
told he died from jumping or falling out
a window about 20 years later more
details about mk ultra emerged and the
olsen family received a settlement and
almost 20 years after that
the case would take another turn
frank olson's wife alice passed away in
1993. their children decided to have
frank's body exhumed and reburied next
to his wife but frank's children had an
additional plan they had james starr a
medical examiner professor conduct a
second autopsy star said there were no
cuts on frank's body and no shards of
glass which would have been expected by
jumping through a window and even though
frank landed on his back his skull above
his left eye had a blunt force trauma
injury he had another serious wound on
his chest
starr said of his findings i think frank
olson was intentionally deliberately
with malice a forethought thrown out of
the window frank's sons sued the cia
again but because of the agreement they
signed in 1975 the judge had to dismiss
the case but the judge did say even
though the case couldn't proceed as a
matter of law the allegations made by
the family against the cia though they
sounded far-fetched appeared to be the
truth since the lawsuit couldn't proceed
frank olson's sons went to the press
they flat out said the c.i.a murdered
their father and covered it up they also
produced interesting documents in 1954
just a few months after frank olson's
death the cia executed a document with
the department of justice that gave the
cia authority to grant cia employees
immunity from any crime including murder
a license to kill exactly and there's a
handbook released in 1953 the year of
frank's death called the cia study of
assassination it's fascinating and i'll
link it below it describes that the best
way to assassinate a target is to drop
them from at least 75 feet onto a hard
surface the manual says when
successfully executed it causes little
excitement and is only casually
investigated in fact the mossad the
israeli intelligence organization used
frank olson's death as an example of a
perfect murder due to the skill with
which it was executed now while there is
still no official admission of guilt
from the cia i think it's pretty obvious
what happened frank olson was one of
only a few scientists who could confirm
that the united states used chemical
weapons in the korean war this is
something that's still only alleged but
there's a lot of evidence it happened
korean and chinese soldiers were
suddenly coming down with cases of
cholera meningitis and even plague it's
possible frank olson was directly
involved in deploying these illegal
weapons frank olson was one of only a
dozen or so people on earth who knew the
extent of mk-ultra and other secret and
illegal cia operations frank olson was a
man who committed or at least was part
of projects that committed atrocities
around the world and he was dealing with
a moral crisis and started voicing his
concerns he even quit but the cia
wouldn't allow it when he was dosed with
lsd that night in november it was a
loyalty test to see what scientists
would say if they were exposed to the
drug frank olson failed that test and
paid the ultimate price but because of
his death and the diligence of his
family many illegal cia activities were
exposed and mk ultra was almost
destroyed
almost it continued for another 20 years
before finally shutting down in 1973 at
least as far as we know all the records
were illegally destroyed and not sydney
gottlieb robert lashbrook or any of the
senior scientists from mkultra were ever
brought to justice in fact they all
lived out their lives on fat pensions
paid for by you and me but the cia
promises that mkultra was the last time
drug experiments were done on people
against their will and such atrocities
absolutely could not and would not
happen today
why would they lie
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment and share i know
you're sick of hearing that from every
youtube channel but it actually does
help so today's topic was a request by
you and if there's something that you
want to see a video on go to thewi files
dot com slash tips we've only scratched
the surface of mkultra and i know it's
been covered to death but if you'd like
to go deeper and there is more let me
know in the comments and special thanks
to our patrons who make this channel
possible i couldn't do it without you
and if you'd like to support the y files
consider becoming a patreon member it's
cheap and it's cool
go to the wi-fi store and grab yourself
a heckle fish t-shirt very gorgeous
they are pretty nice links below
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe
be kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
do
you